so how did you get the idea for gold
belly this seems like
one of the most difficult craziest ideas
to go after because sending perishable
food
having to charge
a massive premium on it and getting
restaurants to pay attention to this
sounds like a terrible idea and just
absurdly hard i mean it sounds
delightful for me to get canisius and
pizza from where i want to eat them
but
what is the origin story here because
this seems like one of the most
difficult unfundable businesses i've
heard of
in 10 years investing in startups
you sound like all the new york vcs in
2012.
yeah i mean i believe in it but i mean
it does sound like a crazy bad what was
the what was the origin here well how
did you come up with the idea and then
how did they respond to it and why did
they tell you you were going to fail
yeah so i think so much of what we do um
comes down to really food love
and the emotional power of food
i think um you know if we trace back
eight years ago give or take
basically i was just thinking about what
the future of food is as far as the
internet goes and you know i went to
college in nashville as you mentioned
earlier from new york originally i was
back in new york after college
and the one thing that i wanted that i
couldn't get were my favorite foods from
nashville oh interesting it wasn't the
other talking about
you needed your new york food in
nashville it was coming back from
nashville what did you need from
nashville
it was coming back so i i went to
nashville as a kid from new york to be
exposed to this whole new world of food
that i had no idea about it was like i
got placed on foodie mars
and
explored hot chicken at places like
princes and eventually hattie bees and
boltons
barbecue
but with dry rub
without barbecue sauce uh from places
like rendezvous
something called meat and threes which
are basically you get some barbecue and
a couple of just classic southern side
dishes
and then uh buttermilk biscuits and a
country ham breakfast from places like
loveless cafe
um
the most delicious food on planet earth
and i'm here in new york city
and
can't experience any of those authentic
real foods from the actual places
and would literally pay anything for
that
and so i craved that called in some
favors to some restaurants they shipped
me these boxes
with instructions how to reheat the food
but really the key moment
was the emotional power that i felt when
i opened that box and i was transported
to a different time and place when i saw
the menus and i smelled the smells
and i think everything traces back to
that magic we're not trying to get you
the cheapest food we're not trying to
get you the fastest food
but we're trying to make food dreams
come true
and make these food experiences the
epicenter of celebrations of nostalgia
of key moments in life
and i think
the more i would ask around to different
folks from different places everybody
had a story of a different food that
they would pay anything for
buffalo wings from buffalo anchor bar
the place that invented them philly
cheesesteaks from hats
the list goes on and on deep dish pizza
from chicago stone crab from down in
miami
new york not so much
the chicago deep dish
for me over ready yeah but i don't know
about this natural hot chicken i mean i
haven't had that and that looks just
banging oh my lord
well do you eat spicy food i'm not like
a crazy spicy food person but i will eat
spicy food and and man that looks just
incredibly tight so you get some of
those restaurants to do it and what do
you learn about
restaurant tours
and their willingness to do this was it
that
you made a high margin and the emotion
of being able to have this experience
was worth the extra 50 bucks or 25 bucks
it takes to ship is is that what this
comes down to
that's the inside so i think it's a few
things
so in the in the early days listen most
restaurant tours were like you know
yeah no like this is a ridiculous thing
i'd like to try
but then there were many that were like
you know what kid this is a crazy idea
but um if you're creating a place where
the best foods from all across the
country can be ordered and and and we're
one of those we'll give it a shot and
see where it goes
and so i think like for the restaurants
this is incremental revenue right like
this is something that's not eating away
at anything they're doing
it's something that's creating a totally
new revenue stream and the way we think
about it we've created the first
platform for national food e-commerce
where before us if you wanted to order
something online shipped across the
country you're ordering omaha steaks
or harry and david pears these kind of
like soulless not really exciting things
so to create a platform where a small
restaurant can enter an e-commerce
economy that they're not a part of at
all like they don't do any business
outside of a five-mile radius
that was interesting to some of them it
had like a legendary dish as you've said
before it can't be
like i'm just
joe schmoe or jane doe with my cupcakes
it's got to be magnolia right and i see
you got the bread pudding from magnolia
bakery which
is just unbelievably criminal i had that
when i was in new york the last time i
didn't even know that existed and now
i'm looking it's it's for sale there
when you uh pitch this idea to vcs
obviously they're gonna say no because
they're gonna think this is too hard
it's low margin
uh
it's manual it's not software i'm
guessing and did you get anybody to say
yes you had to fund it yourself
yeah it was really tough uh in the early
going especially like in the new york vc
community they're just there there
wasn't much love uh there
um you know i funded it myself a couple
of uh friends and family
and then i you know i think our big
break on that side was y combinator
and in uh in 20 2013 end of 2012 we
applied
uh it was the big storm in new york and
basically
like i was bored and just fired away an
application my co-founders had no idea
that i did that we got invited out for
the interview um
and y combinator paul graham and some of
the partners there you know love kind of
those crazy ideas that that
seem too crazy um
and know that there's a lot of potential
there and so they gave us a shot and i
think uh i think that was that was the
first big break and as a team we
actually moved out to silicon valley uh
for the program and stuck around for
four years
before we get to the ad read i want you
to go to linkedin.com unicorn and post
your first job for free at linkedin jobs
that's right a free job posting from
linkedin jobs your founders you're
running a company you need
to get talent in there to help you out
because your company is growing so fast
and you're so busy
time spent searching for and
interviewing the wrong candidates for a
job opening is wasted time you could be
putting that into your customers your
product your team and your vision that's
why linkedin jobs has made it easier to
get the candidates worth interviewing in
front of you and they do it so fast you
can create a job post in minutes on
linkedin and reach the world's largest
professional network of over
750 million people focus on the
candidates with the skills and the
experience you need and use screening
questions to get your role in front of
the most qualified people then use the
simple tools that are built into
linkedin jobs to quickly filter and
prioritize who you want to interview and
hire we love linkedin jobs here at
launch and this week in startups we
hired a third producer we're going to
hire a fourth we got a curriculum
designer working on founder.university
which is going to be a 12-week program
every week 40 million job seekers visit
linkedin you get your first job listing
for free that's right free f-r-e-e
linkedin.com unicorn linkedin.com
unicorn to post that job for free terms
and conditions do apply because they're
giving you something for free